pero casi nadie dice que una planta, o un árbol
o un arbusto tiene cerebro.
Entonces insistimos,
porque esto puede ayudar a describir un poco
cómo funciona realmente el cerebro.
Insistimos y decimos:
"¿qué define si un organismo vivo tiene cerebro o no?"
Y a menudo responden con la clasificación
de que las cosas que se mueven suelen tener cerebro.
Y eso es absolutamente correcto.
Nuestro sistema nervioso evolucionó por ser eléctrico.
Es veloz, para que podamos responder rápido
a los estímulos del mundo y movernos si es necesario.
Pero podemos seguir interrogando a un alumno,
y decirle: "Bueno, tú dices que las plantas no tienen cerebro,
pero las plantas se mueven".
El que haya cultivado una planta
habrá notado que la planta se mueve
para mirar al sol.
Y el alumno dirá: "Pero eso es un movimiento lento; no cuenta.
Podría ser un proceso químico".
Pero ¿y las plantas de movimiento rápido?
En 1760, Arthur Dobbs, el Gobernador Real de Carolina del Norte,
descubrió algo fascinate.
En los pantanos detrás de su casa,
encontró una planta que se cerraba abruptamente
cada vez que un insecto le caía dentro.
La llamó atrapamoscas,
y en una década la planta llegó a Europa,
donde finalmente el gran Charles Darwin tuvo la oportunidad de estudiarla,
y la planta lo deslumbró por completo.
Dijo que era la planta más maravillosa del mundo.
Era una maravilla de la evolución.
Una planta que se mueve rápidamente,
lo cual es raro,
y que es carnívora, que también es raro.
Todo en la misma planta.
Pero hoy vengo a contarles
que eso no es lo más estupendo de esta planta.
Lo más estupendo es que esta planta puede contar.
Para poder demostrar eso,
tenemos que repasar un poco de vocabulario.
Así que voy a hacer lo que hago con los alumnos en el aula.
Vamos a hacer un experimento en electrofisiología,
que consiste en registrar las señales eléctricas del cuerpo,
provenientes de las neuronas o de los músculos.
Me estoy poniendo unos electrodos en las muñecas.
Y cuando los conecte,
vamos a poder ver una señal
aquí en la pantalla.
Esta señal puede resultarles familiar.
Se llama electrocardiograma.
Viene de las neuronas del corazón
que están enviando lo que se llama potenciales de acción,
potencial como voltaje, y acción como movimiento rápido de arriba a abajo.
lo cual activa mi corazón,
y produce esta señal que ven aquí.
Quiero que recuerden la forma de lo que vamos a ver aquí,
porque va a ser importante.
Es una forma en la que el cerebro codifica información:
en forma de potenciales de acción.
Ahora vamos a ver algunas plantas.
Primero, les voy a presentar a la mimosa.
No el cóctel, sino la Mimosa pudica.
Es una planta que se encuentra en Centroamérica y Sudamérica,
y que tiene algunos comportamientos.
El primer comportamiento que voy a mostrarles
es que si toco las hojas aquí,
van a ver que las hojas se cierran.
El segundo comportamiento,
es que si le doy un golpecito,
toda la hoja se deja caer.
¿Por qué hace esto?
En verdad no lo sabemos.
Una de las razones podría ser para asustar a los insectos,
o para ser menos atractiva a los herbívoros.
Pero ¿cómo lo hace? Eso sí que es interesante.
Podemos hacer un experimento para averiguarlo.
Entonces ahora,
del mismo modo que antes registré el potencial eléctrico de mi cuerpo,
vamos a registrar el potencial eléctrico de esta planta; esta mimosa.
Tengo un alambre enroscado alrededor del tallo,
y tengo el electrodo de tierra, ¿dónde?
En la tierra. Es un chiste de ingeniería eléctrica.
(Risas)
Entonces voy a darle un golpecito a la hoja,
y quiero que se fijen en el registro eléctrico
que vamos a ver dentro de la planta.
¡Uy! Es tan grande que tengo que reducirlo un poco.
Entonces, ¿qué es eso?
Es un potencial de acción que se da dentro de la planta.
¿Por qué pasó eso?
Porque quería moverse. ¿Correcto?
Entonces, cuando toqué los receptores,
envió un voltaje a lo largo del tallo,
que la hizo moverse.
En nuestros brazos, moveríamos los músculos,
pero la planta no tiene músculos.
Lo que tiene es agua dentro de las células
y cuando le llega el voltaje, se abre, libera el agua,
cambia la forma de las células, y la hoja cae.
Entonces tenemos un potencial de acción que codifica información de movimiento.
Pero ¿puede hacer algo más?
Veamos.
Vamos con nuestra buena amiga aquí, la Venus atrapamoscas,
y vamos a mirar qué pasa dentro de la hoja
cuando se posa una mosca.
Voy a hacer de cuenta que soy una mosca.
Y aquí está mi Venus atrapamoscas,
y adentro de la hoja, van a ver
que hay tres pequeños pelos; son pelos disparadores.
Y cuando una mosca se posa...
Voy a tocar uno de los pelos ahora.
¿Listos? Uno, dos, tres.
¿Qué tenemos? Un hermoso potencial de acción.
Sin embargo, la atrapamoscas no se cierra.
Y para entender por qué,
hay que saber un poco más sobre su comportamiento.
Primero, la trampa demora mucho en reabrirse una vez que se cierra.
24 o 48 horas más o menos, si no hay ninguna mosca dentro.
Es decir que consume mucha energía.
Segundo, no necesita comer tantas moscas por año.
Solo un puñado; la energía la obtiene casi toda del sol.
Las moscas son solo para reemplazar algunos nutrientes del suelo.
Y tercero,
cada trampa puede abrirse y cerrarse unas pocas veces
hasta que se muere.
Entonces la planta quiere estar absolutamente segura
de que lo que hay dentro es comida, antes de cerrar la trampa.
¿Cómo lo hace?
Cuenta la cantidad de segundos
entre contactos sucesivos con los pelos.
La idea es que, muy probablemente,
si hay una mosca dentro van a ser muy seguidos.
Entonces, a partir del primer potencial de acción,
empieza a contar, uno, dos,
y si llega a 20 y no recibe otro estímulo,
la trampa no se cierra.
Pero si recibe otro estímulo en ese lapso, sí se cierra.
Vamos otra vez.
Voy a tocar de nuevo la Venus atrapamoscas.
Llevo más de 20 segundos hablando, así que podemos ver qué pasa
cuando toco el pelo por segunda vez.
¿Qué pasa? Tenemos un segundo potencial de acción,
pero de nuevo, la hoja no se cierra.
Voy a probar otra vez.
Si yo fuera una mosca que se mueve ahí,
estaría tocando la hoja varias veces.
Así que voy a rozarla varias veces.
E inmediatamente,
la atrapamoscas se cierra.
Entonces aquí vemos a la atrapamoscas realmente haciendo cálculos.
Está determinando si hay una mosca adentro,
y después se cierra.
Entonces, volvamos a nuestra pregunta original.
¿Tienen cerebro las plantas?
Bueno, la respuesta es no.
No hay un cerebro ahí.
No hay axones, no hay neuronas.
No se deprime.
No le importa cómo salieron los Tigers.
No necesita sentirse realizada.
Pero lo que sí tiene es algo muy parecido a nosotros,
que es la habilidad de comunicarse usando electricidad.
Usa unos iones levemente diferentes,
pero en realidad está haciendo lo mismo.
Para que se den una idea
de lo comunes que son estos potenciales de acción:
lo acabamos de ver en la Venus atrapamoscas,
lo vimos en la mimosa,
hasta vimos un potencial de acción en un ser humano.
Esta es la forma de transmitir toda la información.
Entonces podemos usar esos potenciales de acción
para transmitir información
entre distintas especies de plantas.
Así que este es nuestro comunicador interespecie planta a planta,
y creamos un nuevo experimento
donde vamos a registrar el potencial de acción de una Venus atrapamoscas
y se lo vamos a transmitir a la mimosa sensitiva.
Quiero que recuerden lo que pasa
cuando tocamos las hojas de la mimosa.
Tiene receptores de tacto que envían la información
en forma de potencial de acción.
Entonces, ¿qué pasaría
si tomáramos el potencial de acción de la Venus atrapamoscas
y lo mandáramos por todos los tallos de la mimosa?
Deberíamos poder reproducir el comportamiento de la mimosa
sin tocarla.
Entonces, si me permiten,
voy a activar esta mimosa ahora mismo
simplemente tocando los pelos de la Venus atrapamoscas.
Vamos a enviar información de contacto de una planta a la otra.
Ahí lo ven.
Entonces...
(Aplausos)
Espero que hoy hayan aprendido algo sobre plantas.
No solo eso,
ahora saben que las plantas sirven para enseñar neurociencia
y traer la revolución neurocientífica.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)